[Música]
actualización de las noticias económicas
con louis de venta de sobre otra vez un
saludo para usted luis y vamos con la
información de empresas elon mons que se
convirtió en el mayor accionista de la
empresa twitter y la mosca a sí mismo es
ángela y de acuerdo con diversos medios
estadounidenses el empresario de origen
sudafricano habría adquirido alrededor
de 73 millones de acciones para hacerse
con poco más del 9 por ciento de la
empresa de redes sociales y así ser el
accionista mayoritario la noticia
provocó un aumento en la valoración de
las acciones de esta compañía en 25
puntos porcentuales previos al inicio de
las operaciones en el mercado música
había mostrado intención de invertir en
una red social y se decantó por twitter
que le ha servido para divulgar
información por ahora se desconoce el
rol que tendrá el empresario dentro de
esta compañía
y además en turquía están preocupados
por la alta inflación de esto ya
habíamos hablado desde más temprano así
s&p respecto a esta situación hay que
señalar que la inflación alcanzó máximos
de hace 20 años estamos hablando de una
inflación interanual que se ubicó por
encima de los 60 puntos porcentuales en
el mes de marzo según los datos del
instituto de estadísticas de ese país a
nivel mensual el indicador mostró una
variación al alza de
504 puntos porcentuales el informe
señala que tal variación en los precios
al consumidor responde en parte a un
incremento en los precios de la energía
y las materias primas como consecuencia
del conflicto entre rusia y ucrania vale
recordar que la inflación se ha
disparado en el país al tiempo que la
moneda la liga turca se ha devaluado
tras conocerse una reducción de 500
puntos base en la tasa de interés sigue
la crisis política derivada de los
problemas económicos en seeley lanka lo
hemos registrado en noticieros así es y
es que la nación ha afrontado una serie
de protestas que han generado una crisis
política que surge como consecuencia de
la peor crisis económica en la nación
dentro de 70 años o desde hace 70 años
en este caso que han llevado a las
reservas de divisas extranjeras
utilizables del país a desplomarse por
debajo de los 1000 millones de dólares
lo que limita su capacidad para pagar
los préstamos entre ellos el de las
importaciones de combustible que han
generado cortes de energía y escasez de
producto de primera necesidad en lo
largo de la nación
lucia garantiza el flujo de gas en medio
de la expectativa por parte de nuevas
sanciones que podrían llegar de países
europeos sino revela la agencia de
noticias reuters y vaya a recordar que
el anuncio de recibir el pago en rublos
emitidos por el gobierno ruso días atrás
por el gas vendido a lo que considera
país es inamistoso ha generado tensión
al tiempo que rusia ha amenazado con
recortar el suministro si no se cumple
con esta medida no obstante la guerra
que sigue escalando en
ucrania ha generado que diversos países
entre ellos francia han anunciado nuevas
medidas o nuevas sanciones económicas
pero en medio de esta situación algunos
países avanzan hacia una
dependencia del gas ruso entre ellos
lituania que manifestó que dejara que
importar casas ruso en los próximos días
e instó a otras naciones europeas a
sumarse a esta medida por su parte el
ministro de economía alemán informó que
su país avanza para reducir la
dependencia del gas procedente de rusia
y en américa latina' argentina también
combate la inflación y es que luego de
tener una expectativa de que el
indicador presentará un alza entre 5 y 6
puntos porcentuales para el mes de marzo
las autoridades buscan mecanismos para
controlar la inflación y evitar que
sigue impactando el bolsillo de los
consumidores en este sentido se espera
que para esta semana la secretaría de
comercio interior lance un plan que
consta de cuatro canastas con precios
regulados que se sumará al plan de
precios cuidados que presentará una
nueva estructura a partir del próximo
jueves y por favor recordemos los
indicadores que ya tenemos en la jornada
hay que señalar que a pesar de la
atención han mostrado leve ganancia
sobre todos los indicadores en el
mercado asiático que cerraron con
números positivos por lo menos tres de
ellos shanghai no pero hoy por
vacaciones mientras tanto en europa en
los mercados están operando con números
positivos pero con leves en ganancias
muchas gracias a ustedes lo dice y vamos
ahora a nuestras secciones de directo
parís